the most important choice in neil's life
is not his demand
[Music]
how and why did all of you get involved
in resurrections let's start with yeah
yeah then we can go around the room i
got the material i read it and it was a
really really good opportunity you know
um
it was a
character that we it was a version of a
character that you know i had known that
everybody knows you know morpheus and so
but this this this script gave me an
opportunity to do something different it
gave me an opportunity to differentiate
this character from the character that
we had known it you know in the past and
i was doing that in a pretty fun and and
exciting way um
and then it was really you know the
chance to work with lana to work
opposite uh keanu and carrie and step
into that world with amazing actors and
and to see
you know what that what that universe
had in store so all around it was a
pretty uh pretty appealing opportunity
you know that i decided to take on
that's great uh what about priyanka and
jessica um similar i think that it was
obviously as someone who had watched you
know the movie when i was
16 or something and seen the effect that
it has had on pop culture it was amazing
as an actor to want to be a part of a
project that had the kind of legacy it
did and also for me
um i got an email from my agent saying
that there was an opportunity and when i
got the material i did a little digging
and research and i was like oh
oh
oh
understanding and i was like it would be
an amazing opportunity to help be able
to reprise a character that was so
strategically
sort of placed in the previous movie
and to have sort of a pivotal
part in neo's journey it was it was just
really cool and i kind of fangirled
about the opportunity and then went
after it i mean i think you guys put it
really succinctly to add to that i was
actually a huge fan of sense8 which is
lana and the leewski's previous series
on netflix and i
i was obsessed with that i was so sad
when it ended and i was really curious
about meeting the mind behind it so yeah
it was kind of a no-brainer those
questions were yeah yeah now morpheus is
hands down my favorite matrix character
i'm sorry um and i loved your version of
him um was it a lot of pressure to take
on such a fan favorite role and how did
you find that um perfect balance between
giving this morpheus your own spin but
also like respecting the virgin that
lawrence fishburne had initially rushed
to life yeah i think i think that sort
of hits the nail on the head a lot a lot
of it is about respect and and uh
curiosity you know lawrence he he really
put his flagpole in and uh in this
character you know morpheus and uh
it's something that you know people will
that they remember today and that they
will remember forever you know i'm not
exempt from that you know so i just
really approached it with a level of
respect and really gratitude to be able
to walk in those footsteps uh but then
also you know there was an opportunity
to say something new to say something
different you know to honor that
character um but present a character who
was on a journey of self-discovery and
that was the biggest
gift uh you know that that uh
that lana could uh you know give me in
the writing was to present me with a
character who had something to discover
about himself
um that was independent of anything that
had have been done or had been uh
established for him um
in the worlds prior so you know i just
really stuck to the script you know
which basically was my bible and really
uh set myself on a goal to you know to
let that character
rediscover and reintroduce himself and
and um and the rest is just really about
you know gratitude and putting it out
and uh
you know being happy with my performance
and and offering it up you know for you
know for others to come and see
[Music]
you